[Musik]
so willkommen zu einer neuen folge von
4cast in einem podcast heute geht es ums
thema trieb york du hast ja ein seminar
gegeben über das thema das semester
macht mir auch ein link rhein gleich
jetzt wollen wir vielleicht mal einfach
das thema juso für systematischen
kreisen
vielen fällt wahrscheinlich irgendwie
sowas ein wie der sexualtrieb
überlebensinstinkt sind ja auch triebe
manchmal sind wir auch getrieben von
etwas
ich glaube diese sachen werden oft auch
negativ gesehen so wir sind einem trieb
unterworfen manchmal werden sie aber
auch positiv gesehen im sinne von etwas
treibt uns an nicht meine betrieb kann
uns auch gewisse kraft verleihen das was
zu schaffen
bezüglich kreativität lebenszielen die
man sich selbst und das man getrieben
davon jetzt mehr meine frage ganz
konkret so wollen wir gleich anfangen
welche arten des triebes gibt es denn ja
hallo marcel erst mal du hast schon
viele zentrale themen angesprochen die
philosophie beschäftigt sich auch mit
dem trieb das ist erstmal sehr
erstaunlich weil man ja denken sollte
das macht jetzt nur die psychologie oder
die biologie vielleicht die
naturwissenschaften aber tatsächlich
gibt es eine sehr intensive debatte in
der philosophie über das wesen des
triebes und jetzt hast du gefragt was
vertriebe gibt es du hast auch schon ein
paar genannt die philosophie spricht
nicht so viel vom sexualtrieb oder
überlebenstrieb sollen sie spricht mehr
zum beispiel vom spieltrieb also
friedrich schiller hat in seinen
schriften diesen trieb ganz prominent
hervorgehoben ich nach oben rechts link
zu dem seminar dazu rein
es gibt den spieltrieb dann gibt es zum
beispiel noch den ästhetischen trieb bei
fichte und es gibt bei calyon hat
reinhold den eigennützigen und den
uneigennützigen trieb und bei blumenbach
wo ich oben rechts wieder den link
reinmacht gibt sogar einen bildungs
trieb sie ist es gibt eine ganze reihe
von betrieben und die philosophie kann
dazu tatsächlich was sagen
die frage ist natürlich was was bringt
uns das über uns über tipps zu
unterhalten
ja also wie du auch schon sagtest der
trieb ist ein prinzip in der
anthropologie als in der lehre vom
menschen die das erklären kann oder
verständlich machen kann wie wir
überhaupt dazu kommen etwas zu tun als
er trieb er hat immer was von motivation
von antrieb und er hat auch eine gewisse
nähe zum begriff des willens
ja okay da natürlich aber die frage wenn
ich etwas will ich habe jetzt ein bock
drauf urlaub zu machen dann würde ich
intuitiv nicht von trieb sprechen wenn
ich irgendwie ein ziel hat ziele sie
bringen mich auch im wohin dann würde
ich das auch nicht als krieg bezeichnen
also
irgendwie schalten mir jetzt trieb sowas
unbewusstes zu sein was irgendwie
worüber ich vielleicht sogar keine
kontrolle habe das ist auch völlig
richtig
der wille ist in der regel etwas was
reflektiert vorliegt wo wir die vernunft
einsetzen und gemeinhin ist der trieb so
kommentiert dass da die vernunft nicht
so eine große rolle spielt jetzt kann
man aber dennoch sagen die im wille muss
ja eine energiequelle zu grunde liegen
ja woher bezieht denn der wille seine
energie und da könnte man einen trieb
wieder einsetzt und sagen gut am anfang
haben wir so ein bisschen was
unreflektiert ist ohne grund motivation
und die müssen wir aber immer mehr
aufklären also wir müssen uns zu unseren
trieben verhalten mit unserer vernunft
und wenn wir uns zu und trieben
verhalten dann bekommen wir am ende so
was wie den willen und da gibt es eine
ganz interessante neuere position denn
harry frankfurt nach oben rechts auf den
link rein
er spricht von trieben oder begehungen
erster stufe das wäre ungefähr so was
wie der trieb da haben wir auch ein ganz
altes video noch drüber hast du auch
schon mal darüber geredet habe ich schon
wieder vergessen was wenn ich alles
getan haben und es gibt positionen
zweiter stufe dass es dann die reflexion
auf diese begegnungen oder die betriebe
wären das dann nur eine reflektion im
sinne von mir bewusst werden oder geht
diese volution zweiter stufe auch so
weit dass ich irgendwie auf dieser ebene
sagen kann hey ich habe richtig bock
motiviert zu sein für eine sache genauer
also die reflexion die ist nicht nur
abstrakt
die ist auch wiederum energisch oder ja
kräftig strukturiert also ich beziehe
mich nicht nur abstrakt theoretisch auf
meine triebe ist und ich beziehe mich
willentlich oder vielleicht sogar fast
triebhaft auf meine triebe also der
trieb oder der wille wird selbstreflexiv
frankfurt spricht davon dass sich
will das etwas mein wunsch sei oder mein
antrieb sei das ist damit gemeint wir
hatten jetzt kurz zu beginn dieser
dieses themas wille und trieb hatten die
eine klare unterscheidung bzw hast du
das auf gemacht dass wir hier eine
unterscheidung treffen sollten das ist
auch hängt eng miteinander zusammen mir
schien wie können wir das aber noch ein
bisschen trennscharfe machen können wir
so sagen wenn ich mir über meine triebe
bewusst werde das sind genau in diesem
moment mein trieb zum wählen wird wenn
ich das weiterhin in mir behalte oder
gibt es andere aspekte der der trennung
die da vielleicht hilfreich wären ja
also es ist erst mal richtig dass der
trieb wenn er nicht reflektiert ist
nicht mit dem freien willen kompatibel
ist also wir sind heterogen sagt man da
wir sind fremdbestimmt im trieb wenn wir
ihn nicht reflektieren und das hat ja
auch sigmund freud und andere gezeigt
dass wir zum beispiel so ein ehe es in
uns haben ein über ich könnte so ganz
kurz also dieses es gibt ja dieses ich
über ich und er ist diese drei dreier
struktur bei sigmund freud und dieses
ist ja dieser bereich des unbewussten
und stimmt steuern und bewusste antriebe
triebe wünsche und das ist eher was was
nicht uns im freien sinne vorliegt
sondern wir sollten um frei zu sein
unsere motive reflektieren und ganz
kontrolliert einsetzt als geht um
kontrolle dass es unterliegt nicht
unserer kontrolle häufig ne und es geht
darum dass wir diesen trieb dieses
energie prinzipien und reflektieren und
kontrollieren und wenn wir das schaffen
dann haben wir eine wirkliche leistung
vollbracht die uns auch in die lage
versetzt unsere energie zu steuern und
in bestimmte richtungen zu bringen
es geht letztendlich um die arbeit an
uns selbst
also wir sind im prinzip nicht
zwangsläufig den trieben unterworfen
sondern haben immer die freiheit zu
einem freien willen
ja und der trieb ist letztendlich auch
nichts fremdes sigmund freud
unterscheidet ganz prominent zwischen
trieb und reitzig nach oben rechts
wieder und linken
der reiz wird als etwas äußerliches
empfunden dem wir entgehen müssen also
wir müssen zb wenn die sonne in unser
auge zu intensiv fällt dann müssen wir
das auge schließen
das machen wir häufig gar nicht
willentlich sind es geht der flex artige
hingegen ein trieb der wird nicht so
sehr als etwas äußerliches empfunden dem
man entgehen muss sondern als etwas die
man entgegenkommen muss dass man
erfüllen oder befriedigen muss als
antrieb hat eine ganz klare zielrichtung
technologie sagt man
und das ist ein wichtiger unterschied
und deshalb sigmund freud sehr sehr gut
gezeigt als er trieb ist nicht immer wie
es viele philosophen zahlen zum beispiel
man erkannt zu 1 prinzip der unfreiheit
sondern der trieb ist eine chance eine
möglichkeit uns unsere freiheit zu
bündeln zu fokussieren und auch zu
bilden also der bildung ist auch ganz
wichtig genau also das heißt wir können
festhalten triebe sind nach sigmund
freud jedenfalls internalisiert sie sind
im inneren zu finden nicht im äußeren
[Musik]
ja und jetzt bist du auf den punkt
eingegangen mit der bildung wir hatten
am anfang spieltrieb ausbildungszeit
genannt inwiefern kann ich dieses
bildungsgangs bildung verstehen also
bildung bei blumenbach das ist dieser
erste denker der den diesen bildung
streep diesen begriff geprägt hat im 18
jahrhundert der hat die bildung noch
ganz organisch verstanden oder
biologisch also entspricht von einem
polypen einem arm polypen das ist so ein
tier was man in flüssen findet also ganz
einfache struktur dem die arme nach
wachsen wenn man sie zum beispiel
abschneidet und da in dieser hinsicht
spricht er von bildung im sinne von
reproduktion regeneration letztendlich
von bestimmten phänomenen die organismen
auszeichnen dass sie sich selbst
reparieren können dass es sich selbst
aufrecht erhalten also es geht in diesem
sinne erst mal nur ganz allgemein um so
eine zielrichtung in einem lebewesen
sich selbst aufrecht zu erhalten und
auch wenn ihm gewisse teile genommen
werden die wieder nach zu produzieren
in dem sinne ist ja sozusagen unser im
alltags begriff von bildung sehr passend
weil wir in unserer gesellschaft eben
diese schulische ausbildung und bildung
in unserem lebens kontext halt brauchen
um auch zu überleben wie die arme dieses
polit genau man kann dann weitergehen
das haben auch viele denken im anschluss
an blumenbach gemacht und den bildungs
trieb nicht nur auf so natürliche
situationen oder phänomene anwenden sind
eben auch auf geistige also unsere
bildung besteht nicht darin dass uns
arme nachwachsen im gegenteil uns wächst
so gut wie kein glied nach nur so habe
vielleicht oder auch nicht mehr
aber da sind wir jedenfalls gegenüber
der natur anderer wesen im nachteil
hingegen können wir auf einer anderen
ebene der geistigen der intellektuellen
ebene sehr wohl bildung realisieren und
zwar indem sind das wir
gewisse anlagen und vermögen die wir in
uns haben unsere vernunft zum beispiel
das wird die einfach für vollkommen als
auch also eine art von perfektionismus
ist daran gelegen sich zu steigern sich
weiterzuentwickeln
zu guter letzt würde mir jetzt noch
irgendwie mag noch so ein bisschen die
frage für mich offen gibt es bessere
oder schlechtere triebe wir haben ja
natürlich eine unterscheidung gemacht
dass das triebe gibt die dann irgendwie
willentlich werden wenn wir uns dessen
bewusst werden eher in dem sinne könnte
man hier eine unterscheidung treffen und
sagen es ist besser wenn wir uns unseren
frieden bewusst sind so möchte ich aber
nicht machen weil es irgendwie
vielleicht zu einfach erscheinen die
antwort ist ja jetzt schon gegeben
mich würde interessieren bei den trieben
die uns erst mal nicht bewusst sind gibt
es da unterschiedliche triebe und auch
bessere oder schlechtere im sinne
entweder moralisch oder funktional also
in der geschichte der theologie zum
beispiel gibt es auch so hier ansätze
dass man davon spricht es gibt einen
guten trieb und einen bösen trieb indes
als und tourismus das ist ganz altes
gedankengut leonard reinhold ein
philosoph der nach kantischen
philosophie spricht von einem
eigennützigen trieben einem
uneigennützigen trieb ich nach oben
rechts und links ein
es ist dann aber immer so dass die
triebe nicht alleine wirksam sein können
also wir müssen uns immer zu uns an
beiden trieben verhalten und wir können
nur dann frei handeln wenn wir uns
irgendwie einig werden mit beiden
trieben
und deswegen ist immer uns selbst
überlassen welchen betrieb wird den
vorzug geben als es nicht so dass wir
jetzt nur vom einen oder anderen trieb
fremdgesteuert werden sollen betriebe
muss man sich ihr wieso angebote
vorstellen wieso optionen die wir dann
ergreifen können
oder nicht also wir sind nicht von uns
antrieben jetzt zum guten oder zum bösen
hin von vornherein brede terminiert sind
wir haben eben anlagen in uns kann
spricht auf einem hang zum bösen oder
eine anlage zum guten
es sind so grund dimensionen des
menschen und da wird der begriff des
triebes auch nicht mehr richtig scharf
weil er doch sehr stark biologisch co
notiert ist in diesem sinne von einem
trieb zum guten oder bösen sollte man
gar nicht mehr so eigentlich vom trieb
sprechen sind ihr von möglichkeiten
tendenzen was aber doch gemein ist ist
dieses energetische potenzial es geht um
kraft um willenskraft um durchsetzung
und behauptung unentschiedenheit die
unser leben auszeichnet ja interessant
also das heißt begrifflich haben wir
bleibt es einfach kann man sehr schnell
in so einem unscharfen bereich landen
was aber irgendwie den ganzen so eine
zum roten faden gibt ist die qualität
des gefühls vielleicht was man da hat
oder so habe ich das verstanden ja ich
meine der trieb der bezieht sich immer
auch auf unsere natur also der trieb hat
wie ich schon sagt eine hohe
energiedichte und die kann man auch
emotional aus buchstabieren also es geht
letztendlich auch um unsere existenz wie
wir in dieser welt überleben und manche
sprechen auch davon dass ein trieb zur
identität gibt also dass der trieb das
prinzip unserer existenz ist das ist
diese energie die sich durch unser leben
hindurch zieht antrieb ist ganz zentral
und abschließend kann ich eben
vielleicht ja zu sagen hier muss noch
kann noch viel arbeit geleistet werden
so eine philosophie des triebes muss
erst noch geschrieben werden
ok vielen dank gehörten ua für dieses
tolle interview
und dann sehen wir uns bei einer
nächsten folge über das thema des bösen
vielen dank
[Musik]